foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
engineering I worked as a Supply Chain
management consultant I worked with
large companies across Industries such
as retail and Healthcare and help them
to optimize their stages of their supply
chain
[Music]
my name is Christina Grady I'm a
business engineer applying AI to
logistic challenges at Institute in
London
I've always been drawn to heart problems
and been plugging is one of the hardest
unsolvable problems in computer science
this is because there is a very large
set of combinations and functions that
can be taken to find the optimal
solution
being tagging is a theoretically
unsolvable problem however at Institute
by applying reinforcement learning we
were able to get to solutions that
humans would never be able to achieve
I'm working on Deepak Deepak is an AI
powered software that helps to optimize
loads meaning that it can help you
optimize how to pack a set of items in a
container
the algorithm that powers Deepak is
unique for two reasons firstly it is the
first that uses machine learning to
tackle the bean packing problem and
secondly because it applies
reinforcement learning to a very large
scale this is the first of its kind
this helps logistic operators reduce the
costs as shipping additional containers
is expensive and is getting increasingly
expensive in certain cases it would help
certain items getting to Consumers much
faster and by reducing the number of
containers they have to ship they can
reduce their environmental footprints
I am very bad at hiking I wish I had a
software like Deepak to pack for me
foreign
[Music]